me llamo guille y soy inventor o así me
presentaba yo con 5 años y después de 20
sigo haciéndolo porque no porque de
repente yo me daba cuenta de pequeño que
me gustaba reventar la lavadora o
reventar el vhs o tirar el mando por un
noveno piso o saber qué pasaría que
saber qué había dentro y entender las
cosas y de repente llegar los juguetes y
volver a empezar otra vez romper los
juguetes o saber por qué funcionan así o
por qué están diseñados de esa forma o
darme cuenta que las instrucciones era
como el juguete también para mí y darme
cuenta y lo bonito de esto es que he
estado mucho tiempo varios años
trabajando de diseñador de juguetes
desarrollador de producto y no sólo se
queda la pasión en los juguetes en mi
trabajo sino que ésta es mi habitación
al día de hoy o por lo menos una pared
de ellas
darme cuenta eso que mi pasión son los
juguetes y sobre todo diseñar los o
querer hacer mis propios juguetes y
decir ojalá haya una máquina que haga
juguetes o que diseñe juguetes yo cuando
estaba haciendo en mis cuadernos
juguetes o diseños inventos que son los
rivales y los veis ahora madre mía pues
menos mal que ha evolucionado pero por
lo menos tenía esas ideas y esas
necesidades pronto llegaron las
impresoras 3d bueno más pronto que tarde
pero llegaron iba a hacer bueno digamos
cinco años empezaron a democratizarse a
bajar los precios y decirme me voy a
auto regalar una vayan a comprar una y
me compré una súper barata no llegó a
los 200 euros y dije venga esta aunque
sea la peor la cacharros la reviento si
hace falta la veo y voy aprendiendo y
aprendiendo hacer diseños cosas que me
van comprando comprando pero descargando
por internet viendo cómo funcionaba esto
esto me gusta esto es algo que me gusta
y qué bueno pues es un valor añadido a
la universidad que yo estaba haciendo en
ese momento esto lo que hacía un poco al
principio
cosillas squirt es porque me gusta
pokemon o digimon o pikachu por hay
regalos para mi familia yo llevo cinco
años sin comprar nada ningún regalo a
nadie porque puedo hacerlos dije es así
y me diréis guille pero tú vas a hablar
de cosas sociales que estás haciendo es
que a ver empezamos esto gracias a los
juguetes ahora mismo estamos haciendo
que personas pasen de esta situación a
esta otra
y todo tiene relación todo tiene
relación porque porque de repente darme
cuenta que yo podía hacer esto y podía
crear el primer brazo para personas sin
codo que no tiene electrónica y esta
impresión 3d el primero de la historia
sap como es posible que en esta época
esto no existía es hasta ahora y sólo
por encontrarte una por una a encontrar
una problemática que es que ciento mil
cien millones de personas según la oms
no tienen o han perdido un miembro y que
de éstos todo de todos los problemas que
puedes encontrar en este en esta
problemática que es la menor
probabilidad de ser escolarizados mayor
probabilidad de ser desempleados o de no
tener un trabajo digno y por supuesto el
aumento de la vulnerabilidad estudiado
muchísimo decir vulnerabilidad bien a la
pobreza y por supuesto pues todo lo que
yo acarrea que el 17 por ciento o
incluso digámoslo al revés el 83 por
ciento de las personas no puede
permitirse de estos 100 millones no
pueden permitirse un dispositivo que les
ayude en el día a día y por eso eso no
podía quedarse ahí no yo tenía que
desarrollar algo en 2017 hice un viaje
después de acabar la carrera yo me
vieron orfanato ya lo tenía preparado a
kenia y a pintar a enseñar ordenador a
lo que fuese no pero dije voy a ya que
tengo esta posible
voy a llevar estos brazos que encontrado
por internet a algunos y que además he
diseñado unos nuevos que sirven para
estas personas 52 y entonces darme
cuenta que yo podía ayudar a hacer un
plus a este voluntariado internacional
al final pues como podéis ver llevé todo
desmontado porque a ver yo voy a llegar
a las aduanas y me van a decir porque
llevas cinco brazos en la maleta en vez
de ropa y dije bueno pues mejor lo
desmontó lo mezclo con figuritas con
juguetes y tal y así lo llevo siempre la
hubo ningún problema por supuesto pero
bueno allí fue cuando empecé a
demostrarles a mostrarles cómo
funcionaban estos estos estos device
como gracias a las articulaciones de la
persona por ejemplo esta persona que
tiene codo gracias a la articulación
podría abrir y cerrar la mano de nuevo
obtener esta segunda oportunidad y el
resto es la primera vez y era como estar
sé que está funcionando no yo también
estaba muy nervioso y era como venga
pues pues esto es así y tal yo lo
comentaba todo en inglés allí lo
traducía en swahili afín a la
comunicación fue un poco vale bueno
vamos a intentarlo tal esto fue después
de estar un mes allí y nada pues al
final yo me haga cuenta sobretodo de que
lo que sí quedaban era la gratitud
como la sensación de que estaba haciendo
algo por ellos y sobre todo eso darte
cuenta que estabas cambiando la un poco
la situación de mucha gente por ejemplo
la última persona que llegó a recibir
estos y me emocioné un poco
por favor que si no es que esté muy
cerca entonces os veo que estéis como
ostras y me da me choca bueno esta es la
persona que iba a recibir el brazo que
había diseñado yo y que no tenía codo y
sobre todo al principio yo me daba
cuenta que había fallos porque yo lo
probaba con mi la axila
esto funciona esto me lo voy a llevar yo
allí y vamos sin problema al principio
hubo problemas no sé si habéis visto
pero vamos al principio cerraba muy
arriba y fue ajustando y al final no
sólo era un problema del dispositivo
sino que también es un problema de
práctica de que llevaba este rover
llevaba como 12 años sin usarla si no
sabe brazo porque porque había perdido
el brazo en un accidente hacía 12 años
entonces bueno para que se dé cuenta de
la situación esté solamente sientes este
es el después al final te das cuenta que
hay una problemática y que como me voy a
parar aquí no como yo con una cabeza de
ingeniero que iba allí en estos cinco
brazos y me voy a volver a mi casa y voy
a seguir con mis cosas pues no te das
cuenta que tienes que utilizar tienes
que tener esta responsabilidad de
cambiar la situación y al final eso
darte cuenta
que tenía es totalmente diferente todo
lo que te han llevado o sea a mí por
ejemplo el viaje me cambió un poco el
chip no el decir pues como lo vea como
no voy a continuar con esto no tengo
esta tecnología como no voy a seguir con
esto entonces al final cree ayudarme 3d
el proyecto y la misión era clara
entregar brazos a personas de todo el
mundo que lo necesitasen de manera
gratuita
la verdad es que la acogida fue brutal
la prensa se hizo eco del proyecto hemos
tenido muchos reconocimientos y al final
pues eso te das cuenta que el pus de la
prensa y de gente que le gusta el
proyecto pues pues la verdad es que
llama mucho y te da la fuerza para
continuar con el proyecto
de hecho desbloqueas un logro de vida
que es que en matías prats hable del
proyecto hable de ti que la verdad es
que es algo que bueno que dices ya puedo
ya poderme esto es la leche
y luego también eso también centrarte en
que no sólo los proyectos sociales
tienes que mostrarlos en sitios sociales
en eventos de voluntariado en eventos
sociales sino tienes que ayudarte de
gente influyente gente como la vecina
rubia que a lo mejor después de este
stories llenamos un montón de
conseguimos muchísimos seguidores y
además conseguimos centenares de
personas que nos escriben de oye
necesito un brazo para mi prima oye
necesito un brazo para mi hermano si al
final vas llegando a gente que ni
siquiera lo sabes pero que puedes llegar
a mucha gente por ejemplo dani la he que
the street marvel que es un friki de
marvel como yo le dije oye mira te voy a
dar un brazo que tiene el guantelete el
infinito de tanos que a lo mejor si
vosotros os gusta marvel pues sabéis que
es al final es un brazo simbólico o sea
eso él no le necesita no pero al final
esto lo ve gente le ven a lo mejor
millones de personas por todo el mundo y
que nos atrás es que alguien de por ahí
a lo mejor que les sigue lo necesitan o
que puede mostrar el proyecto y
esparcirse el proyecto mucho más al
final proyectos bonitos salen otros
proyectos muy bonitos
este padre necesitaba una bolsa una caja
para cubrir la bolsa quimioterapia de su
hijo y dijimos que él quería una bolsa
de batman y a mí me gusta spiderman no
siento nada al final esta fue un
proyecto como vuelvo a decir una caja
simbólica para que como una comunidad
muy grande de twitter
como por ejemplo gente de twitter muy
interesante que dijo vamos a diseñar
vamos a crear algo chulo entre todos y
vamos a diseñar las cosas guays pero no
solo este chaval sino sino a más gente
vamos a crear nuevos diseños vamos a
hacer para todos los tipos de caja para
todos los tipos de bolsas que existan y
vamos a darle un color a esta situación
horrible que pueden tener en los
hospitales darles un poquito de color a
esa etapa y bueno pues si cuando salgan
pues esto se lo lleven como una caja de
juguetes para guardar juguetes o lo que
les dé la gana y eso y darte cuenta que
tienes que mejorar los proyectos tienes
que decir que si a todos los proyectos
que puedas hacer y que te gusten y que
utilices tu pasión para ello por ejemplo
nosotros nos dimos cuenta que teníamos
otra cosa diferente esto no son lo que
sea estos son tres insectos o es un
nuevo concepto estos brazos para
personas que no pueden permitirse algo
mejor y darte cuenta de eso y empezar a
mejorar y desarrollar nuevas ideas y
nuevos nuevos nuevos diseños sobre lo
que ya tienes la 3 de 6 viking por
ejemplo es el brazo de para personas
-cinco pues mejorar los diseños esto
bueno quien se presente es de esto es
una emulación de todo el desarrollo y
esto mejoran las características físicas
del brazo y digamos que esta es la de
ahora y es que es la mitad o sea el
doble de ligera y no sólo tienes que
balancear el hombro para arriba sino es
que en cualquier en cualquier movimiento
en cualquier lado podría la persona
abrir y cerrar la mano y también darte
cuenta que no puedes hacer todo solo
sino que tienes que juntar te de gente
que confías para crear nuevos proyectos
y crear cosas más más grandes y sobre
todo pues eso crear sus proyectos a lo
mejor o nuevas ideas pero no solo con
las personas que fundase el proyecto
sino que también con colaboradores
colaboradores que tengan tú misma pasión
y que quieran colaborar que gente
experta en impresión 3d porque no va a
hacer estos brazos también por todo el
mundo y también empresas enseñarles a
ayudar a las empresas que muchas
empresas que ya sabréis que no tienen
idea de ayudar pues darles estos
programas para que sepan un poco cómo
ayudar a la gente o colegios porque no
involucrar a los colegios y que sean los
niños y las niñas quien se sientan
partícipes del proyecto y fomentar estos
valores sociales de las nuevas
tecnologías y por supuesto entidades
sociales nosotros al final estamos
creciendo gracias a las entidades
sociales que colaboran con nosotros por
todo el mundo buscando gente que lo
necesita porque
al principio éramos empezamos en kenia
pero es que ahora estamos en más de 35
países y es que es algo que yo realmente
ni me creo y entregando 50 y 150 abrazos
al año al final es la máxima es esta
ayudar es demasiado fácil como para no
hacerlo y darte cuenta de esto es muy
sencillo pero guille
pero tú tienes una impresora 3d gracias
a la ensayada
si es verdad es fácil pero es que si te
gusta hacer sopa fat sopa si te gusta el
inglés enseña inglés a quien lo necesite
o sea utiliza tu pasión para ayudar
utiliza lo que más te guste para buscar
un grupo de personas un colectivo un
vecino que necesite tu ayuda porque a mí
nadie o sea si me llegan a decir que
después de dos años una persona me iba a
mandar este vídeo utilizando el brazo
como si éste la primera persona que
habéis visto la primera que le entregué
después de un año y algo darle esa
independencia a una persona que no
necesita su familia para hacer cosas
típicas tener un trabajo mejor un
trabajo digno un trabajo que que consiga
más dinero o hacer las cosas típicas de
la casa cuando quiera pues al final es
algo que yo no me daba cuenta ni
entonces al final tienes que darte
cuenta de estos de estas ideas y de
centrarte en lo que te gusta para ayudar
a los demás
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y las empresas actuales de las cocinas
sociales las presas nuevas tienen la
obligación de resolver los problemas de
las empresas antiguas los problemas que
nos han dejado las cosas antiguas o las
cocinas
para tener un mundo justo igualitario 7
y sobre todo social y como dijo una
persona que admiro muchísimo y que de
verdad ha ayudado a millones de personas
en el mundo y salva a vidas incluso
podría decir un gran poder conlleva una
gran responsabilidad